you know listen man I can pay sometimes
now I get pissed when I go to a club
house sometimes and they pay me on a
percentage and I look at the check and I
look at that same owner who told me 20
years ago friend there's a Longest Yard
now all he could pay me is 800 for the
week and I want to [ __ ] him punch the
[ __ ] out but at the same time he gave me
an opportunity to improve and guess what
I beat the odds and I get him the games
and so I understand I understand the
fight game I understand what happens I
mean do I support them none I like that
I like to fight us to make money they
get punched in the [ __ ] head this
isn't a [ __ ] job where you go in and
staple papers and go home at the end the
day you know he does something might
happen hard work man he went six [ __ ]
days a week and you saw he had those
what is the example to your liver when
you're [ __ ] 16 [ __ ]
it's a tough [ __ ] life man everybody
wants to get paid I don't think at times
people don't understand the commitment
they have to do to be paid you know I
got it I had over the [ __ ] years
listen I'm live till [ __ ] six years
ago I paid $600 for rent in Hollywood
the studio and my wife you know exam but
you stick with this [ __ ] long enough and
the whole time I was making money all
those years I was just wanting it I was
snoring the smoke and [ __ ] dope and
eating like an animal so you don't do
[ __ ] dick but it's so we Herbie gets
into stuff of money when I got into
commenting it into copy from Libre not
at all I never thought about comedy I
never thought about money in comic when
I would go when I would call you and you
say my club pays 50 bucks I would take
it to me I know how to pay my dues I
always [ __ ] do that then one day you
wake up and you go you know what I'm
gonna not pay my [ __ ] dues I ain't
doing that [ __ ] no more and you make a
constant decision not to do it and
that's what the door opens up for you
it's the people who say I'm not gonna do
it no more then keep doing it then they
will realize when they [ __ ] nobody's
paying me because you haven't made the
decision after the strike in this town
the movie business try
that oh I would submit myself 20 times a
year for movies plus my agents for some
memory I was working all the [ __ ]
time then there was a strike in town and
everything disappeared so people started
contacting me for these YouTube [ __ ]
movies you know you got to bring your
own clothes or holiday that's the big
one this time 100 hours a day so that
and you don't know it when you book the
movie but it's a night shoot because
they can't afford to pay for locations
so everything is a night shoot in a rush
you got a little strip club to shoot at
4:00 in the [ __ ] morning what I did
like for those things I said one day you
know what I'm not doing this no more and
I kept getting calls kept getting calls
kept getting calls and I refused to do
those [ __ ] things and one day I
grudge match did they pay me yeah but at
least I got a big kind [ __ ] a movie I'm
not wasting my goddamn time it's not
till I made a constant decision let that
happened you know saying then I said
like when I was a comic there was a lady
who didn't [ __ ] like me when I first
started for me to get back in her I
would do her rooms for free I would call
her up the day of the gig you know I'm
gonna go down there and do a guest spot
because I knew that it would just make
me stronger than she was a piece of [ __ ]
anyway I was going to show I was better
than [ __ ] she was and the club owners
were asking how can we don't book him
and she was telling some story all he
does drugs I don't want to book them
whatever [ __ ] story she's dead I'm
still [ __ ] alive and thinking like a
bad [ __ ] that I had the moral
the story is it's like when a fighter
with your home in your home and you see
a fighter get up and go I just want to
fight I don't care what they pay me you
like you [ __ ]
be the same thing with comedians there's
to me that's why when I first got to the
store when that made that remark I said
the place is packed
I'm gonna give you fifteen [ __ ]
dollars and what a man you said if you
don't want to be a take your name off
the [ __ ] list I put a [ __ ] map out
there I'll do a sign-up list with you
one o'clock in the morning so many
people sign up for it you don't know how
lucky you are but you always want to get
what you deserve also you know but for a
while yeah couple dicks in the ass and
that that's the way the [ __ ] ball
bounces even Mike Tyson got [ __ ] in
the air inside even Mike Tyson somewhere
along the line
something happens there you got to watch
your back like a [ __ ] you